[Music]
why did Jordan cry when he was
explaining what he had to do to win and
whether or not he would be remembered as
a nice guy by his team I've thought
about this I think there's something
like you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
don't get it like you sit here and you
[ __ ] judge me yeah and essentially
it's like he doesn't even get to enjoy
all the [ __ ] that he did like him being
the greatest was for everybody else for
him it's just blood sweat tears
sacrifice sacrifice sacrifice hard work
hard work hard work and now I'm 50 and
I'm 60 and I'm super competitive and I
have nowhere to put this mm-hmm I did
this for you and you sit there [ __ ]
judge me like who worked harder than
Jordan does he feel judged do you think
that's where it comes from I think he
feels underappreciated I think he feels
judged I think he feels like people tell
me I'm so competitive and I'm and I'm an
[ __ ] teammate and this and that y'all
don't y'all don't know what the [ __ ] it
takes to be this yeah it's it's I don't
knows I couldn't fully figure it out
because I caught me I said were you
surprised when he started crying oh yeah
where they come from so just to clarify
every but for everybody's listening
there's a moment in the documentary I
think I forget what you up it wasn't a
pisode saying we treat both of the
episodes like they're the same one so
it's one episode and it's ended up
episode seven yeah and I think the
interviewer asks him like how do you
feel about the perception that you might
not be a nice guy Yeah right and he goes
yeah maybe I'm a tyrant you know or
maybe I'll be looked at as a tyrant and
setter people call me all these names
but you've never won anything in your
life who said yes you know it takes
which is the bar but he's for me he's
starting to get a little defensive here
yeah right I've rarely seen Jordan
explain himself but you're starting to
see him explain himself in his
documentary you rarely see great to
explain themselves themselves and then
he starts to go into this feeling of
like what he had to do in order to win
and he goes listen I want to win don't
get me wrong but I also wanted them to
have that as well I don't know if I
believe that I don't believe that I
don't believe it either so he wanted to
win he knew what it took for him to win
yeah and he felt this was the only way
to win and this
now he was gonna get the most out of
guys with him and if they couldn't
handle it get the [ __ ] out of it and
then he says that line where he goes
this is how I play the game and if you
want to play you can get out of here let
me take a break he starts crying yeah I
think you're starting to see the effects
of of life an old age right on the
effects of mortality I think Jordan at
one point time was immortal and I think
that he had this godlike presence right
and what happens is when you see that
people no longer view you in the same
godlike way you start to be accountable
for your actions
interesting right like when you really
think about Jordan like he's curse on
all these people that he just made a
hundred percent more times their salary
for them yeah right Jeb Bush lers not
getting paid what he got paid right
prior to Michael Jordan be in the league
along with everybody else NBA player
today makes more because of Michael
Jordan 25-year 100% so he knows what
he's offering an organization he knows
what he's offering all these players so
he's demanding the most out of them he
sees that as the only pathway to victory
and that's fair right and I want to get
into another conversation but are there
other pathways to victory but I really
think you're starting to see like when
he walked around before this was
literally God and I think now Jordan can
walk around a bit I think now Jordan can
go to the Country Club
I think he can go maybe he's not going
to malls but I don't know if kids are
looking at Jordan the same way we did
you know it's crazy because I had this
thought and I just had it and didn't
think anything of it yeah I thought
about meeting someone someone had like a
picture of Michael Jordan on his cell
phone 15 years ago or something like how
the [ __ ] were you even around him and I
yesterday I was like you know what I
would be awestruck for sure if I saw
Michael Jordan yeah but it wouldn't be
the same level of I don't know how to
function as a human being at all right
now he was a Beatle yeah he was a Beatle
- he was all the beat yeah he was he was
all - Beatles he was yeah the most
recognizable person in the world at one
point time and there's no doubt that
he's recognizable now but maybe he's
starting to feel the effects of that
mortality and I think when you realize
you're mortal you realize what life is
you start going oh
[ __ ] did I hurt people when you're
caught up in the game right and and I
felt this even playing sports myself
like you get caught up in the game you
don't care if what you say to someone
you're playing with hurts their feelings
you don't care about any things and then
after the game you're like [ __ ] I should
call somebody that's Jordan times a
million yeah and I feel like now as he's
watching the way people spoke to him
spoke about him as he's watching like
what happened to people in their lives
and as he's seeing people actually as
human beings as he's kind of limited
some of that competitive drive because
that's just what happens when you get
older I think he's starting to go whoa I
might have [ __ ] hurt people and I
think he's trying to justify it to
himself I think he's trying to go this
was the only way to win and this is how
you had to do it hmm you know the way I
took it Jordan
appears to be very sensitive and he
sometimes he uses like what people say
about him as motivation for what I've
got to win but when he doesn't have the
game or an outlet or a place to battle
it yeah he doesn't know how to handle it
so like when they were accusing him of
having something to do with his dad
getting killed like he couldn't channel
that into winning a game to make him
feel better so yes I think that was a
big part of the reason why he stepped
away from the game right and so I think
with this it's almost like he doesn't
realize the way he'd navigates life or
the way he motivates himself is unlike
anybody else like he thinks this is done
this is normal if you want to win if you
want to be a champion this is the way
you go about life and then now to hear
everybody and he has he's been hearing
this for years all Jordan was rough he
was [ __ ] and she liked that so I'm
mad and you're hearing this over and
over and over this is nothing you can
possibly do to change that perception
and in his head he was like not but I
just wanted to win like why is everybody
else not thinking the way I think and I
think I just frustrating for him and
that's probably why he cried that's
that's what I'd so something like if I
win
everybody will be silenced I don't have
to be sensitive anymore because nobody
will hurt me because I won all the time
you can't question me winning yeah but
now I won all the time and you've still
found a way to criticize me and I'm
still sensitive to the criticism yep and
I can't just go out and beat you like I
normally did because there's no way to
criticize after I retire he was a bad
me I can't go back in time and be a
better teammate we wouldn't have won
probably yeah I think I think what you
realize like when you start to achieve
certain things that you really want and
you assume that like certain things will
come with that like let's say you're
like oh if I get famous Dan all these
people are gonna like me right yeah and
then you start to realize like oh no
like my friends like me based on how I
treat them right and like the
similarities we have and the love that
they feel for me and the love they have
like that's how friendship works it
doesn't really matter if you win a
championship ring and all these other
things and I think like once you remove
yourself from competition you start to
realize like what the important things
in life are yeah you know and and then
maybe he a little part of them is like
[ __ ] like I had a lot of relationships
that I torched to get these rings and it
was great and I think I'm the best and
all that kind of stuff but man it'd be
cool to have some friends because all
these [ __ ] I don't know he's
gotten the point where he realizes all
of it outwardly though because he hasn't
done the Kobe thing post retirement
where he channels everything into yeah
I'm a better person being a better
father being whatever I think you
realize it I think he's trying to fight
it okay okay he hasn't had the he hasn't
come to grips with the truth that's the
emotional break yeah the emotional break
is he's still convincing himself he did
the right thing it's like it's like
maybe like this is crazy to compare it
to but like you know maybe like a
soldier that had to do some foul [ __ ]
yeah to survive in Vietnam but he was
like that's what it took and we needed
to win and I needed to get my men home
so I had to blow up that Hut but who was
in the hut it didn't matter who was in
the hut I need to do what it took you
don't say and I think he views his life
in that way and now as he reflects on it
he's like the souls are going there
might've been some [ __ ] kids in that
hut but I had to do it I had to do to
save my platoon but I don't want to
[ __ ] kill right I think he ever had
to worry that because winning cures all
right right like there's this thing
about winning man where if you win you
were forgiven for whatever the [ __ ] you
had to do we to this day all of his
teammates who hate him there's really
nobody on his team it likes him they
respect him they
like him here's what I noticed this is
actually yes the points it was like they
don't like him but they respect him yet
but they don't like her Yeah right and I
feel like because he won you get that
respect but they don't like the
difference between winning and losing is
Michael Jordan Chris Paul Chris Paul is
Michael Jordan if he never won right
nobody likes Chris Paul right and few
people respect him yeah they're like
yeah he's good B not good enough to win
he's definitely not good to talk to me
like that definitely not good enough to
curse me out yeah you know nobody would
have spoke like that to Jordan because
they know yeah I could I must forgive
you for this because we are here again
right yeah
were you sin to your point about him
nobody really likes him I do think like
BJ Armstrong was on the Sports Center
after and he seemed to that he's still
like Jordan overall like he still likes
him but you're watching this thing do
you remember what it said for Jordans
personal assistant the description of
his product for a slash best friend yeah
your best friend is your personal
assistant yeah like something about that
seems so [ __ ] warped to me yep this
is the guy that I have go get me cigars
and scotch for and that's my best friend
he like he's just my [ __ ] Lackey
who's also my best friend
yeah how many friends do you have I mean
when the guy who's dead to hang out with
you is your best friend he replaced his
dad with another dad yeah but he's like
now you have to be with me all the time
the guy was like okay and that guy
probe's kids yeah yeah right but like he
was he was inserting these people into
different roles in his life that he
needed filled yeah and it's a brilliant
thing to do because he had that singular
focus I mean it was genius the guys are
genius but he is maniacal in his
approach to the game and it's just I I
guess it's a good time have this
conversation which is like is there
another way to win
[Applause]